left thought that they would push the
sex narrative Donald trum this bill and
that networks are doing it
round-the-clock it is non-stop and they
thought that that would crack him no
that would crack him crack his support
it reminds me of the Billy Bush tape
when that came out they thought that was
it we've stuck a fork in him he's done
again they don't want to debate Trump on
the issues they do not want to talk
issues they want to demonize and isolate
him and destroy him that's the left's
tactic look at this piece of video this
is CNN they convened a group of
evangelical women and they thought well
we'll rattle them we'll play some stormy
Daniels for them this is what happened
why would she come out and give this
interview if she wasn't telling the
truth do any based on this interview do
any of you believe that stormy Daniels
did have sex with Donald Trump I don't
believe it because I haven't seen any
hard proof or a stripper porn star I go
with the President of the United States
this is a rooster farm why are we giving
it any credibility so why they stick in
vile well they're sticking by him
because remember during the campaign I
went out in San Awards at polling places
now I encountered a number of angelical
xand Catholics and I said why in the in
the light of the Billy Bush things are
you voting for this man they said that's
right and they said we believe he said
check not only on our government that's
going away we didn't like it to go but
on our churches that have also gotten
very political they're talking about
environmental issues in climate change
and we don't agree with that they said
they see the president as a check in all
those areas and look at look at the
agenda and the record he's installed the
Mexico City policy which keeps us from
funding abortions abroad he's changed
and dropped the Obamacare regulations on
Parenthood now in planned parent well
planned parents abatement he still has
to stop the funding of Planned
Parenthood which he promised and
conscience protections which he promised
to put into the law particularly still
waiting on that but they are willing to
give him the benefit of the doubt also
for a man who's not particularly
religious he speaks and talks about God
with regularity
Angelica like I sort of remember the
lighting of the Christmas tree by God I
heard Jesus mentioned that much was a
lot
Graham was alive ya know it was really
unbelievable no it was a very hard
saying happy season's greetings yeah
holla Santa Claus it was all about the
baby in the manger I'll be making a
religion the Pope sent everyone over the
edge but through this interview he did
with this 93 year old skull father's
golf re yeah I'm gonna tell you
newspaper La Repubblica 93 years old
he's interviewed the Pope five times is
the Pope still doing interviews and he
thinks he's gonna convert him he thinks
he might convert him and and they're
friendly they had they see the world
politically I think in the same way but
look stuff re claim the Pope said hell
does not exist we'll put it up on your
screen Jonathan what exists is the
disappearance of sinful souls I won't go
further because we're running out of
time
yeah well there as hell does not exist
what exists is the disappearance of
sinful souls they are not punished those
who repent obtain the forgiveness of God
and go among the ranks of the souls who
contemplate them and that's it those who
do not repent therefore cannot be
forgiven they disappear be gone you have
no power here they disappear now as you
can imagine all of Christendom was up in
arms when this headline hit Pope says
hell does not exist Good Friday thing
well this is the second time Skull fari
is said the Pope claims he'll does the
point of the resurrection because if you
want to avoid going to hell right that
Jesus died yeah for sins and to keep
people from going to hell Nevada can
quickly issued a retraction but listen
to the retraction and this has caused
also agita among some people listening
they said the article is the result of
his reconstruction skull farak in which
the exact words spoken by the pope are
not quoted no quotation marks in the
above article should therefore be
considered as a faithful transcription
of the Holy Fathers words now that's a
non-denial denial I mean so people are
still wondering what does that mean I
realize an interpretation of a
interpretation the language wasn't
exactly what he said but the question is
substantively did skull fairy capture
with the Pope meant I doubt it because
the man has spoken about Satan and the
the lures of the devil for a long time
but they should just come out and do try
this and clearly saying the
believes in hell and this is a big
misfire all right well now Walmart is
removing Cosmo enough time talk about
their moves in Cosmo that's the big deal
they don't want little girls seeing out
that sex and how to please your man now
good good there we are
be good fry by happy good fried